so you'll need to work it so the
pressure is
so it keeps with it all the time
have we got it
that's how much you need
to do aikido
but if it bounces
then it means that your connection is
going in and out
when you're in both got weapons in your
insanction
most of your mind will be
is he going to attack is he going to go
now are we go you know so your mind is
like this
if you can go
light and be completely open
when this happens
this feeling
so what i'd like you to do is the person
next to you know two four six okay so
you're left
so they're going to open their hand
and you're going to
you're going to do that and you can feel
that
yeah at the end okay
feel it all the way then
okay
so you got without touching it
so i'm about what uh
two three centimeters perhaps away from
his hand
and i want you to each other to feel it
from the start to the finish
all right and if you don't feel it at
first but you say like uh i felt at the
end then i have to concentrate harder
on the point here so i'm going to that
point there so now i've got it
now it'll feel all the way
okay
that's how subtle aikido really becomes
at my level i'm not doing technical
aikido i'm doing
energy on what i'm feeling from the
person
you know somebody comes quick with a
punch
you know what you're gonna
jump flinch
you know
okay so with your partner